Move over, Doctor Strange — there's a new
Sorcerer in town.
"We're all gonna die!"
The MCU's Peter Parker may feel like he has
the weight of the world on his shoulders,
but at least he has a few good friends watching
his back.
Peter's friend Ned proves to be exceptionally
useful in the Holland-led threequel "Spider-Man:
No Way Home."
It's not just his intelligence that helps
Peter conquer the day; in this movie, it's
his magical hands — literally.
Ned must have some sorcerers somewhere in
his family tree because once he attains a
Sling Ring — the device Doctor Strange uses
to create portals — he's able to use it
all on his own, doing it just about perfectly
on his first try.
To say this comes in handy in the movie is
a pretty major understatement.
Matter of fact, his sorcery directly leads
to the movie's coolest moments.
It's safe to say hardly anyone had "Ned becomes
a sorcerer" on their "Spider-Man: No Way Home"
bingo card, but that's precisely what we got.
At the very least, Ned becomes incredibly
proficient at using a Sling Ring in a short
amount of time.
Whereas it took Stephen Strange quite a while
to get the hang of making portals, Peter Parker's
right-hand man figures out how to do it almost
immediately -- although he apparently still
needs to learn how not to immediately close
them after somebody walks through.
It's a fun addition to the "Spider-Man" canon
and plays a significant role in several moments
throughout the film.
The most notable instance of Ned's Sling Ring
proficiency coming in handy is when he and
MJ want to find their Peter.
But when he merely says "Peter Parker," we
get Andrew Garfield's version of the character
and then Tobey Maguire's.
"Pizza time."
It's a fun way to bring all of the Spider-Men
into one place.
However, whether Ned's set to join the ranks
of the sorcerers himself in the future is
still very much up in the air.
During the heartwrenching "No Way Home" finale,
Holland's Peter asks Doctor Strange to make
everyone in the universe forget about Peter
Parker.
He doesn't merely ask to make people forget
Peter is Spider-Man; he asks that Strange
wipe out his existence from peoples' memories
completely.
That means Ned forgets all of his memories
of Peter, too.
By that logic, it would make sense for him
also to forget he can tap into magical powers.
Who knows if he'll ever remember the power
he holds in the palm of his hands.
Ned being a magic user isn't just a fun thing
they added to Ned's character for the movies.
His character's namesake from the comics,
Ned Leeds, has a villainous alter-ego as one
version of the Hobgoblin — one who's also
proficient in sorcery.
This is exemplified in the storyline for "Symbiote
Spider-Man: Alien Reality."
In it, Ned, a.k.a. Hobgoblin, decides to work
alongside Baron Mordo, who's played by Chiwetel
Ejiofor in the MCU.
Hobgoblin steals a magic book at the Sanctum
Sanctorum called the Word of God, which allows
the user to alter the universe.
Through this, Hobgoblin's able to make Mordo
the Sorcerer Supreme while Ned becomes his
apprentice.
Suffice to say, nothing like that happens
in "No Way Home."
While Ned learns how to use some magic, it's
limited to making portals via a sling ring.
He doesn't go full evil just yet, but there
is a line to suggest Ned could become Hobgoblin
down the road.
After Tom Holland's Peter Parker meets the
other two, Tobey Maguire's version tells Ned
about how he fought his own best friend, Harry
Osborn.
"Look at little Goblin Jr. Gonna cry?"
The story seems to really stick with Ned,
and he immediately turns to Tom Holland's
Spider-Man to inform him that he'll never
turn evil and fight him.
It's a fun line, especially for those who
are aware of Ned's comic book alter-ego.
And with Baron Mordo returning to the MCU
with a villainous role in "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness," who knows what
could transpire?
Perhaps the two characters will meet one day
in the MCU after all.
"You're an F.O.S. now — 'friend of Spider-Man'
– and you have to remember, just stay calm."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.